welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Marvel's echko a new series
dropping all of its episodes on January
10th 2024 on Disney plus Ekko Stars a
Locka Cox reprising her role as a
mercenary from the Hawkeye series and
Vincent denafo stepping into the white
suit once again as Wilson fist Kingpin
but soon that suit's going to be red
because our man thinks he's still on
Netflix yikes this trailer makes the
show looks so good and I know there's
been concerns about Ekko but if the show
just lives up to this trailer it's going
to be fine we're going to have a lot of
fun by the way I am wearing our new
shirt that we just dropped inspired by
Ekko on our merch shop over on nerd r.
shop it features EC H spelled out in
bloody hands in ASL yeah you better bone
up on your ASL before this series starts
unless you want Kingpin to release his
fists okay let's dive in we open on
young Maya Lopez played once again by
Darnell bauw alaka Cox's real life
cousin who appeared in Hawkeye episode 3
and melted our hearts she still looks
really young here and those of us who
attended d23 in September 2022 saw a
completely different trailer for echko
principal production for this Echo
series took place in April 2022 which
would have been right after those
episodes of Hawkeye came out I wonder if
this could have actually been a deleted
scene from the Hawkeye series because we
know there was another deleted scene
with Wilson Fisk at May martial arts
class that ends with them going to get
ice cream so maybe ice cream to these
two means ice cream from a different
place than this street vendor who we
left with this face cave Den in an alley
right beside Maya's school just a
reminder that the Hawkeye series from
2021 went into Maya Lopez's backstory we
actually first saw Maya as a kid in 2007
where she was attending a school and
then training in martial arts her Father
William Lopez was a commander in the
tracksuit Mafia he couldn't afford to
send Maya to a specialty school for deaf
people but encouraged her to learn how
to navigate a world that didn't account
for her disability it was in her karate
class that Maya first met kazzy casmer
who would end up being a close friend of
hers throughout her life along with her
Uncle Wilson Fisk who kind of plays a
secondary paternal role to her as she
Grew Older Maya would join the tracksuit
Mafia herself but would ultimately
witness the death of her father at the
hands of Clint Barton in 2018 you
remember this is during the blip where
Clint had lost his entire family and
went into this dark vengeful Ronin stage
of his life and started killing people
in the cartel and yeah a lot of people
in the tracksuit Mafia now in the
Hawkeye Series in the present day Maya
Lopez would learn of Kingpin and K's
involvement in sticking the Ronin on the
tracksuit Mafia and would get her
Revenge by stabbing kazy to death and
shooting Kingpin in the eye executive
producer Sydney Freeland confirmed in a
Variety article that they have
reimagined the character making her now
a member of the Chaka tribe from
Oklahoma Marvel actually released a
whole version of this trailer in Chaka
on their YouTube channel so we see Maya
here going to a private school for girls
in New York City and an ice cream vendor
sets up outside to sell two kids despite
being an absolute terrible person he
mouths the words I don't know what
you're saying at a little girl Wilson
Fisk returns again in a signature white
suit as seen in Daredevil season 3 on
Netflix Fisk has a whole closet of the
same white suit we hear fisk's voiceover
saying I see everything that you are now
remember in 2007 that little moment with
Maya would be taking place before the
Netflix Daredevil series before the
Battle of New York before Tony Stark
declared I am Iron Man which Marvel
Studios has considered their year zero
Fisk charges up to ice cream man his
shoulders and traps and bald head
filling the frame looking like that
Kingpin Big Boss Shadow silhouette over
the city in the Hawkeye credit sequence
and I love the audio design of this
trailer when Fisk punches a vendor the
hit and the scream Echo throughout the
next
seconds this is something they do
throughout the trailer while Maya is of
course deaf those punches just seem to
hit with such an impact that it feels
like this is something she could sense
through the ground vibrating the Marvel
Studios logo is in black and white and
cracked like the wall we see later same
colors in font as the echo logo Wilson
fist carefully cradles the vendor's
cheek and for a second we think he feels
bad but no he's just raising the guy's
face so that he can punch him again and
we see fist's hand shaking just like it
did after he beat down guys who's
particularly mad at in the OG Daredevil
that ring he's actually had on since the
finale of Hawkeye young Maya stares
unfaced at Fisk knocking out that ice
cream man and we transition to Ekko with
red light light on her face signifying
our sweet young girl is a coldblooded
killer now she wants to be as soaked in
blood as Uncle Wilson is we're at a
roller skating rank as she smashes
through a sign that says make America
skate again so does Donald Trump exist
in the MCU all right we see Maya
visiting a grave likely that of her
Father William Lopez who was killed in
2018 by Ronin looks like she's holding a
red tracksuit jacket with white stripes
which would be the jacket William Lopez
War when he was a member of this group
looks like a freshly dug grave so this
would be right after William died which
again was 2018 in the MCU timeline
during the blip we see ekko's prosthetic
leg as she steps off her motorcycle now
in this shot this guy coming out through
the door the graffiti says margarito
this is actor Andrew Howard you might
remember him from Perry Mason season 1
on HBO and several other titles we
actually saw him in Agents of Shield he
played Agent Luther Banks rightand man
of Rosalind price he was a hunter of
Inhumans rumor has it the black knife
cartel could appear in the series this
guy kind of looks like T door zaro now
we see bodies on the ground outside of
this same warehouse the their bodies are
on fire sometime after he walks out of
this Warehouse the place is going to
blow up so we see this woman named Chula
played by actor tantu Cardinal who
stares off in the distance during a
prayer session While others sing from
himels tantu is actually recently in
killers of the flower Moon playing the
mother Lizzy Q This appears to be a
Chaka Christian Church Christianity is
pretty prevalent among American Indians
and specifically Chaka who converted in
wide numbers we hear a voice over at
Kingpin saying so much rage and the word
rage Echoes to the beat of the trailer
we see Kingpin standing in front of
piece of art it is most just Shades of
Gray but it's similar to the white
painting he loved so much in the Netflix
series from the rabbit in the snowstorm
episode of Daredevil season 1 when he
told Vanessa and made him feel alone
actually we realized later in Daredevil
season one that his fascination with the
painting was that it reminded him of the
chipping and peeling paint on the wall
of his childhood apartment that he
stared at after clubbing his father to
death now we have not seen kingpin's
cuff links since the finale of Hawkeye
and even then they weren't really
revealed until Clint's coin trick even
in this shot we don't see them just the
ring that's been on forever we see Ekko
wielding something that's weapon can't
really tell what it is kind of looks
like a piece of Machinery now long time
new rockstars viewers know how much we
use geology and how long we've been
using it for but if this is your first
time hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
G's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
loose oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one of the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to geol log. i/
rockstars 100 to get started so the
actress Dey Jacobs you might know her
from reservation dogs plays Bonnie on
the series she seems to also be in the
skate life roller rank as Andrew
Howard's character points a gun at Maya
and someone else both with their wrists
bound then we see this woman maybe Maya
Lopez's mother giving birth in the woods
during a rainstorm we in a hospital gown
we never learned of Maya's mother in the
Hawkeye series and I always get nervous
whenever we see the moment characters
are born like with Neymar and black
panther W kind of forever because
between that mythology from what G to
Forever and the mythology of how blade
was born from a woman who's bitten by a
vampire while the baby was in the womb I
just don't want another scenario where
her PO came from something that happened
when she was in the womb I just think
there's enough misinformation out there
about what happens to a baby while it is
in a womb okay here we see a group of
indigenous people watching some sort of
activity or sport based on the buildings
and clothing appears to be taking place
in the past it could be playing
stickball which is a full contact game
that is still played today and it was an
early precursor to what became known as
lacrosse stick ball was a sport played
by the Chaka tribe traditionally
anywhere from 100 to 1,000 men would
compete in these events that could last
several days this was more than just a
game though as sometimes these stickball
events would help keep the peace between
the tribes who participated in them
there have been documented games going
back to the mid 17th century these games
served many purposes as they could
settle disputes toughen up Warriors for
battle be part of festivals or even just
settle a wager but here it looks like a
woman is playing it seems like
traditionally it was the men who played
today though women do participate in the
sport okay this dude get shot in the
neck holy crap not the kind of violence
we're used to see it on Disney plus but
it gives us a sense of why this series
is going to be rated ma like the end of
the trailer tells us hey you got to go
on Disney plus and like uh change your
settings this trailer is presenting this
series to be very very violent and dark
and you know what I I'm here for it I
think the MCU has desperately needed
this kind of raw violence in it next we
see Wilson Vis leaving a dead body on
the runway as he boards a jet while Ekko
is going up the stairs just in front of
him executive producer Sydney Freeland
confirmed that she will be a villain on
this show she said quote we wanted
something that again if you're coming
off of Hawkeye and you have to keep in
mind she's a villain and so tonally we
wanted to lean into that I think in
talking with the executives and our
approach and when building visual style
it was sort of like oh yeah lean into
that lean into that and a shot that
seems like it's part of the stickball
sequence in the past we see this super
muscular Warrior emerging onto the field
then Maya gets pinned onto a pinball
machine this pinball machine is Old West
themed a cactus a coyote on a mountain
it's probably some problematic depiction
of American Indians in the old west and
whoever pined her on is going to say
something offensive then we see some
indigenous people dancing in ceremonial
Tire you can see the dancers are
numbered 60 and 61 it's probably a
modern event though there's a quick shot
of a wounded bird in a box pretty sure
this is a male red-naped sapsucker then
a close-up of this guy bleeding from his
mouth nose and eyes spay across the
table we actually saw this poor dude in
The Wider shot at the snack bar of the
roller rank then a monster truck driving
over some Vans squeezing the armed men
inside this shot of the city as
something explodes in front of it is
composited that's New York City in the
background seen from Brooklyn but they
added a train yard in the foreground
something on the track explodes this
could be the explosion we saw the
results of earlier in the trailer now
there's a very quick shot here that's in
black and white the d23 trailer actually
had a lot of black and white footage
from like a 19th century battle on a
prairie it looks awesome from what I
remember but this trailer is kind of
deemphasizing that aspect of the series
in favor of like grittier modern
violence in the style of Daredevil and
Punisher from outside of pent we see
sign language for alligator I don't know
if this connected but there is a chock
doll Legend called the alligator in the
hunter a man who was bad at hunting went
to hunt and found a weak alligator whose
swamp had dried up the alligator said
that if the hunter carried him to water
he would make him a great Hunter he
carried him to the water and the
alligator taught him how to be the
greatest hunter like which animals to
kill to ensure that there are always
animals there to have more young okay
very very quick shot of Charlie Cox as
Matt Murdoch back as Daredevil in the
series his costume does look darker it's
certainly different from the red and
yellow suit that he wore on she She-Hulk
Crazy Action here I love the shot Maya I
think leaping From a Train onto a truck
as it pursues a train on the track then
a very quick shot of her eye with
something reflected in it it kind of
looks like Daredevil in that reflection
then part of scene it looks like it's
going to have some pretty wild action
Maya standing in a doorway a guy shoots
another guy in the shoulder then we see
two guys in front of Maya she kicks a
chair at the second one the guy in the
front is wearing a shirt that's say
Security on it she kicks him in the leg
she grabs him by the neck and then it
cuts to fisk's beat down on the ice
cream man so the two fight sequence are
being linked she beats a security guy in
the same way Fisk beat the ice cream guy
and then as Wilson Fisk says you and I
are the same I hate that he says that it
is like he's trying to claim her ability
to be hostile and violent when I think
the point of this is that Maya Lopez
through her Father William was born into
a struggle that Wilson Fisk had no part
in I think her fear in the series is
going to be turning into a brute like
Wilson Fisk is but she's not the same as
him throughout this we get some very
very quick shots showing us some
interesting imagery we see a woman in
white looking scared we see an IV d RP
Ekko with a gun at her head quick shot
of wheat in a field then Ekko hugging
someone in a red tracksuit I'm pretty
sure that's William when he died in that
Hawkeye flashback we see some light
between tree leaves we see a woman's
hand grasping at fabric maybe the Hem of
her dress we see the disco balls in the
ceiling of the roller rink made to look
like a planet with rings Ekko on her
motorcycle Ekko doing some pretty
painful chiropracty on a guy and then
finally young Maya Lopez holding hands
with Fisk after she caught him beating
that ice cream guy we end the trailer
with Wilson saying
so
who's the
monster monster a very loaded word in
the MCU historically it's been spoken by
women in a way that's not great like w
maximoff saying I'm not a monster I'm a
mother in Multiverse of Madness or an
age of Ultron when Natasha Romanov told
Bruce Banner you still think you're the
only monster on the team right after her
heartbreaking story of the way she
underwent a forced hysterctomy in the
Red Room graduation ceremony I think the
word is better coming from an [__]
like Kingpin here because the insult is
put upon her and now it'd be up to Maya
how to respond to it like hopefully
telling Wilson to go himself you'll
notice that Wilson Fisk has an eye
injury here likely a result of mayia
shooting him in the eye at the end of
Hawkeye sometimes family doesn't see eye
to
eye the moment mirrored a similar event
from Daredevil number 15 written by
David Mack drawn by David Ross in 1998
that was a comic Where She Blinded
Kingpin after she learned of his
involvement in her father's death and
this would be when he's wearing the same
white on red kind of the reverse Santa
outfit that he wears in the Hawkeye
finale so Wilson Fisk recovered from
that with just a missing eye and that
seems to be the case here now another
thing that a lot of people are talking
about for the series is the way the
executive producer Sydney Freeland is
apparently updating ekko's powers in it
the quote in the Variety article that a
lot of people have some thoughts about
is this she said her power in the comic
books is that she can copy anything any
movements any whatever it's kind of lame
I will say that is not her power which I
got to say uh look I'm still very
excited for the series but you know I
think a lot of times these TV show
Runners don't really know who the
readers of the comics are and what their
expectations are leading into these
shows and maybe shouldn't just kind of
go off script and interviews like this
I'm praying you Marvel Studios invest in
putting all your showrunners all your
writers anyone who's going to be doing
press on your show to just do a little
bit of media training so that you don't
piss off the fan base before they watch
the show I think it's going to be good
but between this and some of the things
Ali Saleem said promoting secret
Invasion like come on but what do you
think her powers are going to be if it's
not going to be to mirror everything is
it going to be something closer to that
of Matt Murdoch I am very very excited
for the show and again it is streaming
January 10th aha so while I will
definitely be watching these episodes in
early January I will be out on
fraternity leave because our baby is
coming at the end of December new
rockstars is still going to be doing
Episode by episode breakdowns but we
will have a special guest covering for
me at that time announcement coming soon
don't worry you'll still see me on New
rockstars I'm just not going to be
covering breaking news at the same
Cadence I am currently doing I'm going
to need some time to be a good Papa I
want to give a huge huge thanks to
Jessica Clemens Brandon barck Gina AO
and Eric Francisco for helping me write
this breakdown follow me on all social
platforms at eaos follow new rockstars
grab one of these ech shirts at nerd.
shop and come hang out with us at our
live show on November 16th thanks and
I'll see you next time everyone
bye